hi there today we're looking at deep
image reconstruction from human brain
activity by Gua Shen tomoyasu hotei cava
ke majima and yukia's ooh cami Thani
this is like reading thoughts so I was
excited when I saw this paper I saw this
on reddit and it is a bit older it is
from the beginning of last year so I'm
sure there have been developments in
this area but basically what this paper
does is it will have a human look at a
picture as you can see for example right
up here it will measure the MRI activity
then it will use a what they call a
feature decoder in order to map that MRI
activity to features of a deep neural
network and then they will reconstruct
the image that is closest to those
features in the neural network and by
reconstruction they get basically they
get out an image of what the human sees
so we're going to explore this pipeline
right here but it's pretty cool and if
it works you know it basically means
that we can read someone's thoughts but
of course there's going to be issues and
problems so first of all this is all
visual they measure the activity in the
visual cortex right here so let's break
it down to the individual parts the
individual parts here the fMRI that is a
machine we cannot control right so you
measure the fMRI activity and that's
basically measures which of these cells
in your brain use oxygen it's it's
functional fMRI it's not structural so
it measures which ones are active and
that's how you would see which parts of
the brain brains are active and I think
the resolution on these things has
gotten very very good so you can make
out very fine-grained activation pattern
in the neurons and they measure the
visual cortex which is the part
responsible for basically visual stimuli
so for seeing things now they need this
this feature decoder but because
ultimately what they want to do is they
want to have these features correspond
to features in a neural network this DNN
here is a is like a vgg I think a vgg 16
or a vgg 19 it's called a vgg 16 network
this is a couple of years ago these
architectures were very popular for
imagenet and they're fairly basic so
what that means it's not like a a super
duper inception net where you have like
layers within layers and so on they're
pretty straightforward convolutional
neural networks with nonlinearities and
pooling here you can see there is a
bunch of layers then there's pooling
there is a bunch of layers there's
pooling and so on so what you want to
look at are these layers of the deep
neural network right the individual
layers and you want to you want to
basically put an image right here into
the neural network and then observe its
features in the neural network and then
you want to put the same image through
the human and then you observe the MRI
features and you know that this is the
same image so you can basically learn a
feature decoder this is going to be
another sort of machine learned maybe a
neural network I haven't actually read
this could be just like a linear
regression or a neural network just a
regression from that map's the fMRI to
the features so this is what you have to
learn basically they took a bunch of
humans stuck them in an MRI machine
right cut out their their fMRI data for
the same image so for a given image X
they got the human fMRI data and they
got the vgg the gg they got the features
when they put the X the image through
the neural network and now they learn a
function that minimizes the error so
there is an error so basically they run
this on a test set of images and then
you end up with a function that can
basically map fMRI features to neural
network features now the second step now
you you can you can give the human let's
say this works you can give the human an
arbitrary image and it the human will
basically interpret it through its
visual cortex you measure the activity
in the visual cortex and then you can
predict the neural network features if
that image were given to the neural
neural network okay but now you you
don't give the image to the neural
network instead of what you do you do
something like deep dream does that
means you start from a noisy image at
the beginning and you try to find the
image so you start from this noisy image
right here and through iterative
gradient descent you refine this image
that's this arrow right here you've try
to find the image that as closely as
possible in the internal representation
matches the features that you predict
from the fMRI signal because these are
the features that the neural network
should see right if your if your feature
decoder is good these are the features
that the neural network should output
for that image
so you're basically trying to find this
image right here but you're not looking
at it you only look at the features that
should be in the neural network so after
a bunch of steps of refining that image
you hope you basically end up with an
image that corresponds to these features
and then you you you can look at it and
it usually looks something like this
we're used to these kind of things from
neural networks and if I invite you to
look at something like the open AI Atlas
if you want
to understand how this is done but
basically we can get the image that most
faithfully corresponds to these features
now this doesn't always work super well
because there are actually since the
neural network is sort of a dimensional
reduction technique there are many
images that correspond to the same
features and they often end up like
really weird so what they do is they
have this deep generator network as a
prior basically this is D generator from
again from a generative adversarial
Network so this network right here is
really good at just producing naturally
looking images and now because we have
that our task is not going to be to
start from this image right here our
task will be to do the exact same thing
but with the input to the deep generator
Network so basically what we're trying
to do is we're trying to find the input
vector to the deep generator Network
such that these features right here
correspond to the features that we
predict from the fMRI activity and
because the deep generator network is
trained to produce natural-looking
images this will always give us sort of
a natural looking image no matter what
our input vector is so there by week
basically constrain the optimization
procedure to only output natural-looking
images so let's see how well this works
so these are the reconstructions I have
to say their training set their training
and testing set so up here this
procedure where we learned right here
this would be done on a training set of
images and then they expose the humans
to testing set of images so this
reconstruction right here would happen
on images that the feature decoder
wasn't trained on but the humans are
looking at it so the humans are would be
looking at the picture here on the left
and then this would be to the right
you'll see as more and more iterations
of this process of reconstructing
happens the image gets
basically clearer and clearer and you
can see on the right you get pretty good
looking images for the ones on the left
now these researchers they tend to they
tout the success like they say ah look
look at this but you know honestly like
this is a leopard this is a dog sheep
this is an owl this is a dog so you know
this is a fish and this is a like a
shell like a muscle so I'm and you can
go through these and basically you know
this is a sled and then this is a truck
so they go basically and they say wow
the accuracy is really good so they do a
pixel correlation accuracy which is you
know you just try to pixel correlate
things but they have human judgment the
accuracy via human judgement is over 95%
that's crazy but how do they do it so
basically they tell you okay see this is
the image at the beginning no sorry they
give you this image right here as a
human Raider and then they give you two
other images they say okay here are two
images let's say these two which one did
it come from and if the human can can
determine it correctly counts as a hit
so the baseline probability here is 50%
so basically right is so so this right
here is it rather than owl or is it
rather the VCR and I mean in that
respect it's pretty impressive what you
can read from a brain but in no way like
zero way this is reading your thoughts
this isn't like it seems to basically
just reconstruct a example from the
image net training
set and the imagenet explorer is down
right now so I I try to look at this but
it seems to me it's just kind of
reconstructing something it knows that
sort of RIT resembles the image on the
left yeah but it is not it is not
reconstructing that image not at all
like look like a bit but vaguely vaguely
but they do some more investigation into
this okay so well first of all here you
can see what happens without this deep
generator network so when you have
unconstrained search then it is even
worse right you get like big pixel
meshes right here so you need this this
kind of prior over natural images but
the prior I think the prior here comes
through a bit much because I the prior
might be in part responsible for why the
images just show something else then you
see they go into an investigation of if
and they discover if you use more layers
to reconstruct the reconstruction gets
better so here according to human
judgment if you just reconstruct from
the first layer you don't get very good
reconstruction but if you incorporate
the signal across many layers of the
neural network so you're basically
trying to match to predict many layers
of signal different layers then the
reconstruction gets really good and you
know we know these from things like
style transfer you can modify how close
you are to the original or to the target
by basically seeing which layers and how
many you reconstruct to which accuracy
so this makes kind of sense so if you
only take the first layer and to match
the features then you get basically this
blob here but if you get layers one
through seven you get pretty pretty ok
ish thing that looks like this thing I
guess these are without the deep
generator Network so far but now that
that is interesting and I think the
novel thing here is one of the novel
thing
that they actually use multiple layers
of the neural network to reconstruct the
interesting thing is I think think this
is this is pretty cool they can now do
this with these shapes so these shapes
aren't natural images and they have not
been seen in training but still as you
can see when the human sees for example
the plus shape it will get you a pretty
clear plus shape and it happens for a
lot of these things right here so these
are actually I would say fairly
okay-ish reconstructions of what the
human sees here neuron that is fairly
neat and for the alphabetical letters
and shapes you see again the even the
pixel correlation now is pretty high but
human judgement again high and here the
human judgment kind of makes sense right
if you ask is it like this shape or this
shape then it makes more sense to
evaluate it like this so the shapes I am
fairly impressed that they can
reconstruct these shapes and what
they're now trying to do is they're
trying to infer imagined images so
basically they're telling a human please
imagine an image and they show it to the
human it's so it's not really imagining
it's basically recalling they show you
this image and then you whatever close
your eyes they take the image away and
you just try to imagine that and you can
see through the reconstruction process
that works out you know sort sort of ish
right you can see that the cross here it
kind of comes through and this the plus
kind of it sort of comes through and so
these are the high accuracy these are
actually the samples where where it
worked and there are also samples where
it didn't work like here where you see
it doesn't really come through that so
they're either there is you know really
a difference between imagining something
and seeing something or
this method just isn't very good per se
and you actually need or humans aren't
really good at imagining like there's
lots of explanations and here is the
same thing if you imagine these images
now they report that if humans just
recall or imagine these images then the
reconstruction doesn't work at all so
that might be to the fact that you know
you cannot in your recollection you
basically just remember the important
things about something you don't
remember the exact pixel values and
therefore your visual cortex doesn't
respond in the same way I mean it's
interesting even per se to think about
it but I have my doubts about you know
this entire system so I don't want to
make too many conclusions here about
these things suffice to say that
sometimes it actually can read your
thoughts because if you just think so
this is this stuff up here if you just
think of a shape it can sort of kind of
a bit make out the shape that you're
thinking about all right this was it for
this paper I'm basically mainly you
wanted to show you what I found and I'm
I'm I have to say I'm pretty impressed
with this even though like this is a
laptop this is not a VCR this is a VCR
it's it's more of a nearest neighbor
thing really than I reek instruction I
think but that's my opinion right yes so
if you like this give it a like
subscribe if you're still here
and I look forward to next time bye bye